there's a whole set of expectations that
are governing what we're doing like you
don't want me to take your your little
tablet there and smash it that would be
shocking right you wouldn't know what
the hell to do right you'd be somewhere
different if I did that and you wouldn't
know where you were and that's another
thing to know because that's a
fundamental difference there's a
fundamental difference between knowing
where you are and not knowing where you
are I think it's in some sense the
fundamental difference you can think
about it as the distinction between
explored and unexplored territory but
you have to I don't know if you've ever
taken a cat to a new house cats hate
that and because in their old house and
maybe in their old neighborhood they've
slunk around you know at the edges check
and eye everything out they start out
fray afraid they check everything out
they know where to hide they know where
to they do what they do they know what
what's safe and they know that because
they go somewhere and nothing happens
and so then they assume that it's safe
and they slowly build up a neighborhood
that they're comfortable with my dad
used to take the dog for a walk and then
the cat got lonesome and so it started
to follow him and first of all it would
just go along the building's the houses
on their route you know hiding really
from predators and after a while I got
kind of comfortable with that and then
it would follow right behind the dog but
it had a border and if my dad took the
dog over one Street too many for the cat
the cat would just sit on the corner and
you know cry like a cat cries it was
like that's it for me man I'm not going
any farther out into the unknown
and so the distinction between the
territory that you have mastered and the
territory that you haven't mastered is a
fundamental distinction
it's the distinction between Holmen and
the strange land and the thing about
familiar territory for people is that
most of the familiar territory that we
inhabit is
other people because we're so social she
can't really think it's a weird way of
thinking about territory it's not
exactly geographical objective territory
its territory with a dominance hierarchy
in it and the dominant hierarchy has a
predictable structure and you know where
you fit in it most of the time and so
that when you act out in that territory
surrounded by your people then often you
get what you want and you're so thrilled
about that because you just don't want
someone acting erratically around you
like and you know that so you walk down
Bloor and there's people there that
should really be institutionalized but
we D institutionalize them all so they
could be free and free to be you know
suffering and malfunctioning out on the
street that's what the freedom ended up
being but you know you'll walk by
someone like that who's muttering away
to the voices in his head and you know
maybe striking out against whatever it
is that's plaguing him and you will make
eye contact you might even go across the
street you're certainly going to give
him a wide berth you're going to keep a
distance between him and you and you're
going to hope that you don't attract his
attention because he's not in the
dominant hierarchy and you don't know
what the hell he might do and that's
unexplored territory too that's another
way of thinking about it like we inhabit
time and space not just space and not
just time we inhabit time and space and
our territories our spatial temporal
we're here now and this is safe now and
it's safe partly because of the physical
structure and it's working but it's also
faith because none of you are
manifesting peculiar behavior but if you
started to manifest peculiar behavior if
you stood up and started muttering or
yelling or maybe attacking someone next
to you all the rest of you would freeze
first because then all of a sudden this
would be unexplored territory the match
between what you want which is a
peaceful lectures that you hope has some
content
the match between what you want and
what's happening has vanished and so
then you're not you don't know where you
are and so then what do you do when you
don't know where you are what do you do
when you don't know what to do well if
you're a computer you just crash but you
know what good is that to you you're
just gonna die that isn't helpful you
freeze first and then maybe you costly
cautiously attend or maybe you don't
maybe you just keep your damn body's
averted and you sit there and you hope
that no one notices you that's a
predator that's a prey response right
that's like a rabbit frozen when it
thinks that Fox is looking at it and we
were prey animals for a long time there
was a cat that they recently discovered
a prehistoric cat that had this bottom
single tooth and they found out that it
a human skull fit right inside its mouth
and so it could grab you here and Pierce
the back of your skull with it with its
single tooth and that's what it was
evolved for so you know it's under such
conditions we evolved and we're
predators obviously but we're tasty
predators and so other things were
perfectly happy to eat us and so when
you're where you don't know what to do
you act like a prey animal that's
probably what you should do because
maybe if you keep your head down and
shut the hell up there will be any
attention attracted to you and maybe
you'll get through it
you know you might decide unlikely to
intervene and take the guy down but but
you would be the exception rather than
the norm and it's unsurprising